well perhaps you've seen the recent
videos they show some of the violence
that's been taking place in our local
schools clark county school trustees
agree it's a pressing issue that's
affecting education now the question is
how to move forward this morning there
was a meeting held to try and start the
conversation hector mejia joining us
live this afternoon with some of that
discussion hector
and board members agreed to come back on
march 10. trustees want an overview of
the current policies they want to know
what's been done so far and include ccsd
police in this conversation
after a 90-minute special board meeting
clark county school district trustees
voted 4-3 to come back and have a deeper
look at the current policies for
violence and school safety according to
the teachers union violence is on the
rise and they want transparency our
staff and educators are the ones that
are in the buildings and they see it day
in and day out and so they're concerned
is this really being reported are
parents aware of what educators are
dealing with friday morning trustees
spent much of the time trying to figure
out clear instructions for staff members
and deciding what they wanted to hear in
the next meeting your briefing will be
in the meeting like if we have to
educate the superintendent and his staff
on what data is we have bigger problems
than this right now no one is making
that truck
i'd like to call a point of order
um it is inappropriate i know that the
new appointed board members
we went over policy so i would
suspect
as an elected official that you would
read the policies
and that was some of the back and forth
that stood out this time trustees also
wanted to read a report released to
channel 8 it was a public records
request that revealed so far this school
year there have been more than 5 300
calls for service the top incidents
included assaults fights harassment and
threats on school grounds reporting near
flamingo mcleod hector mejia live local
now